n'importe où dit belfort et on vous
répondra le lion le monument de barton
10 et l'image de la ville chaque année
il accueille 80 mille visiteurs mais
l'image de belfort c'est aussi la ville
industrielle et de garnison peu
attirante pour les touristes c'est cela
que le conseil général du territoire le
faire changer une étude préalable aux
assises a montré que la clientèle
touristique du département est composé à
35% par des gens de passage
objectif affiché les retenir longtemps
de petite taille le territoire de
belfort n'en comporte pas moins de
nombreuses richesses un exemple le lac
du malsaucy 40000 visiteurs par an pour
des activités nautiques et de baignade
actuellement la clientèle du plan d'eau
est surtout composée de gens venant de
la proximité
les responsables motoriste veulent faire
du lac un argument de promotion du
département
et puis le territoire de belfort c'est
aussi une partie du massif vosgien avec
notamment le ballon d'alsace
mais jusqu'ici l'aménagement de ce
sommet a un peu souffert du fait de
l'écartèlement du site entre quatre
départements
la fondation d'un syndicat mixte
interdépartemental et surtout la
prochaine création du parc naturel
régional des vosges du sud devrait
permettre une meilleure concertation à
plus de 1200 mètres d'altitude ballon
d'alsace est un argument de poids pour
le développement touristique du
territoire
sport plein air mais aussi patrimoine à
l'association départementale du tourisme
veut mettre en place un produit vendu
clé en main avec ses 27 ouvrages la
ceinture fortifiée de belfort pourrait
par exemple si elle était exploitée
attiré des milliers de visiteurs
en somme le potentiel touristique existe
reste à mettre en place une politique de
communication pour vendre une image de
marque